The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: The second
carbohydrate biosynthetic
pathway we're going to look
at is called gluconeogenesis.
Gluconeogenesis is the
synthesis of glucose
from noncarbohydrate precursors.
Let's look at Panel A of this
storyboard, Storyboard 31.
There are some organs in the
body that require glucose
as their metabolic
fuel, yet they
don't have the capacity to
make it, or to make much of it.
Examples are the brain, renal
medulla, red blood cells,
and the testes.
To give an idea of the scale
of the problem the body
faces, we only have about 200
grams of glucose or glycogen
stored away in our body, and the
brain alone uses more than half
of that each day,
so we don't have
much in the way of a
carbohydrate reserve.
The body compensates by having
certain organs, specifically
the liver and renal cortex, act
as specialized manufacturing
centers to produce
and export glucose.
The chemical raw
materials they use
include organic acids such
as lactate, some amino acids,
and the three-carbon residues
from odd-chain fatty acids
that enter catabolism.
To get an idea of
how gluconeogenesis
works, let's take
a look at the box
here at the bottom of Panel A.
You see a muscle working very
hard, as evidenced by the fact
that it's secreting
lactate out into the blood.
The lactate travels
from the working muscle
by the blood to the liver,
where the lactate is taken in.
The pathway of
gluconeogenesis, with energy
and reducing equivalent
input, rebuilds glucose
from that lactate precursor.
The glucose is then sent back
out into the blood, returns
to the muscle, enabling the
muscle to continue hard work.
As I've described
earlier in 5.07,
this functional relationship
between a muscle and the liver
is called the Cori Cycle.
Let's look at Panel B.
Depending on how you look at it,
there are seven
or possibly eight
noncarbohydrate precursors to
glucose in gluconeogenesis.
They're listed in this panel.
And I've indicated
these precursors
by numbers 1 through 8.
The first seven are
not carbohydrates,
so they qualify as
noncarbohydrate precursors
as fits the definition for
a gluconeogenic compound.
The eighth is actually
a carbohydrate.
It's ribose.
I'm semi-illegally
squeezing it in here
because ribose acts as a major
gluconeogenesis precursor
by way of the Pentose
Phosphate Pathway, or PPP.
We haven't covered the
Pentose Phosphate Pathway yet,
but we'll see, when
we do cover it,
exactly how this pathway
works to manufacture glucose.
In other words,
ribose from the diet
can be converted into glucose
by way of the Pentose Phosphate
Pathway coupled to
gluconeogenesis.
A little bit later
in this lecture,
we'll see how each of
these precursors-- that is,
numbers 1 through 8--
are converted to glucose by
the pathway of gluconeogenesis.
The best way to start
thinking about gluconeogenesis
is to think of it as
glycolysis running in reverse.
As shown here in
Panel C, glycolysis
is conversion of glucose,
ultimately, to pyruvate.
As we know, that pathway goes
with a net generation of ATP.
That is, it is exergonic.
Accordingly.
If we go from pyruvate
back to glucose,
we know that in order to make
that reverse pathway exergonic,
we're going to need
to have energy input.
As we learned earlier, there
are 10 steps in glycolysis
going from glucose to pyruvate.
Three of those steps are
thermodynamically irreversible.
Those are the steps
that commit molecules
to flow from left to right,
as drawn in this panel.
The thermodynamically
irreversible steps
of glycolysis are first,
hexokinase/glucokinase,
that is, the conversion of
glucose to glucose 6-phosphate.
The second irreversible step
is phosphofructokinase 1,
the conversion of fructose
6-phosphate to fructose 1,
6-bisphosphate.
The third irreversible
step is pyruvate kinase,
the conversion of
phosphoenolpyruvate
to pyruvate.
We have to find a way
in gluconeogenesis
to bypass these three
thermodynamically irreversible
steps.
The enzymes that were invented
to circumvent the three
thermodynamically irreversible
steps of glycolysis
are shown in green
asterisks in this panel.
For example, glucose
6-phosphatase
hydrolyzes the sixth phosphate
from glucose 6-phosphate,
converting it to glucose.
A second asterisked enzyme of
gluconeogenesis is fructose
1,6-bisphosphatase,
which converts fructose
1,6-bisphosphate by hydrolysis
to fructose 6-phosphate.
The third irreversible
step that we need to bypass
is pyruvate kinase.
Two enzymes were invented
to enable this bypass.
Pyruvate carboxylase,
which we have
studied before in
several contexts in 5.07,
and a new enzyme,
phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase, or PEPCK.
Pyruvate, carboxylase,
and PEPCK work
in a partnership with
several other enzymes,
actually in a mini-pathway,
to bypass the pyruvate kinase
step of glycolysis, and
hence, enable gluconeogenesis.
Lastly, at the
right of this panel
is a large inverted L. This
is meant to symbolize the 8
precursors to gluconeogenesis.
These precursors will enter
the gluconeogenesis pathway,
and flow by the
hatched arrow lines
all the way up to glucose.
This network of reactions allows
the conversion of molecules,
such as the amino acid
glutamate, all the way
to glucose.
Now we're going to
turn to Storyboard 32.
Let's look at Panel
A. And let's start out
by looking at the mechanisms
by which the four key enzymes
of gluconeogenesis works.
The first two enzymes, glucose
6-phosphatase and glucose
1,6-bisphosphatase, carry
out simple phosphate-ester
hydrolyses as shown.
The third enzyme is
pyruvate carboxylase.
We looked at this
enzyme mechanistically
back in the fatty acid
catabolism lectures,
when I taught about the
mechanisms by which CO2
can be captured and
added to an organic acid.
Pyruvate carboxylase
will convert
pyruvate to oxaloacetate.
Hence, it's in an
anaplerotic enzyme
that helps maintain the
levels of TCA intermediates.
In the cases we've
looked at so far,
PC helps maintain specifically
oxaloacetate levels.
Refer back to the
lecture on carboxylases
to see how this enzyme works
from a mechanistic perspective.
Now let's look at Panel B.
The last and fourth key enzyme
I want to discuss
in gluconeogenesis
is phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase, or PEPCK.
We haven't seen an enzyme
that works like this before,
so let me go through its
mechanism in some detail.
PEPCK is going to
convert oxaloacetate
to phosphoenolpyruvate.
The enzyme is active in
the liver and renal cortex
under physiological conditions
that mandate gluconeogenesis
be turned on.
The enzyme takes oxaloacetate,
which, as we know,
is a beta keto acid.
Thus, it's prone
to decarboxylation.
When CO2 is removed
from oxaloacetate,
you get a transient pyruvate
enolate, which is an anion.
The oxygen anion of
the pyruvate enolate
will attack the
gamma phosphate, that
is, the terminal
phosphate of GTP,
and thus, the pyruvate enolate
will become phosphorylated.
The product of phosphorylation
is phosphoenolpyruvate, or PEP.
Hence, the concerted
action of two enzymes,
pyruvate carboxylase
and PEPCK, enables
reversal of the
otherwise irreversible PK
step, the pyruvate kinase
step, and allows the cell
to do gluconeogenesis.
Let's look now at
Panel C. Now that we've
seen the identities of
the eight precursors
to glucose in
gluconeogenesis, and we've
done a little bit of learning
about the mechanisms of some
of the key enzymes
in the pathway,
we can turn our
attention to a network
analysis of the overall
gluconeogenic pathway.
The pathway in this panel
may seem a bit daunting,
because it's pretty
much everything
we've learned about
metabolism so far in 5.07.
So let's go through it
slowly in little pieces.
Let's start over on the left,
where the glucose molecule is
situated in a squiggly box.
Note that the glucose
in the squiggly box
is being sent out of the cell--
that is, it's going in
the opposite direction
from the direction in which
we have dealt with glucose so
far in metabolism.
Usually, we think of glucose
as coming into the cell
and entering metabolism.
This is a liver
cell or renal cortex
cell that's in the
process of manufacturing
glucose from those eight
precursors, the ones I
mentioned above, and sending
the manufactured glucose out
into the blood.
In this metabolic map,
the hatch lines-- that is,
the lines that look
like railroad tracks--
represent that
gluconeogenic pathways.
Now let's start walking
through the metabolic map.
Slightly to the right of
the middle of the diagram,
you see the amino acid alanine
and the three-carbon organic
acid lactate.
Lactate is precursor
number one in my scheme.
The numbering,
again, is in Panel B
of the previous storyboard.
And alanine is
precursor number two.
Let's start with lactate.
Lactate would typically come
into the liver from the blood,
perhaps from a working muscle.
Think about the Cori
Cycle for a moment.
Lactate dehydrogenase
will convert the lactate
into pyruvate in the liver
or in the renal cortex,
in the other
gluconeogenic organ.
Let's look next at alanine.
Alanine, gluconeogenic
precursor number two,
is, of course, an amino acid.
And a PLP-mediated reaction
will convert it to pyruvate.
That reaction involves
specifically the loss
of alanine's amino group.
Now imagine the
resulting pyruvate,
that is, from either
lactate or alanine,
translocating to the right
into the mitochondrion, where
it's carboxylated by pyruvate
carboxylase into oxaloacetate.
This is the reaction mechanism
we looked at a short time ago.
Now remember that malate
dehydrogenase, or MDH,
thermodynamically favors
the formation of malate
from oxaloacetate.
So our two molecules navigating
the gluconeogenic pathway--
that is, precursors one and
two, transit from oxaloacetate
into malate.
Malate is in the
mitochondrion at this point.
In the next step, it
exits the mitochondrion
and goes into the cytosol.
As I've mentioned before,
the transporter for malate
works in both directions.
Malate, now transported
into the cytosol,
can be converted
back to oxaloacetate
by the cytoplasmic version
of malate dehydrogenase.
The oxaloacetate thus
produced in the cytosol
goes upward, following
the vertical arrow.
Lastly, PEPCK,
phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase, converts
the oxaloacetate
into cytoplasmic
phosphoenolpyruvate.
Let's pause here for
a minute and review.
Look at where
phosphoenolpyruvate
is on the metabolic map,
and then look to the right.
On the right,
you'll see pyruvate
on the rightward side
of the one-way arrow.
You will also see lactate and
alanine, molecules one and two,
respectively, having
their carbons flow
into the pool of pyruvate.
The pyruvate pool, which
starts in the cytosol,
gets shuttled into the
mitochondrion, where
pyruvate carboxylase converts
the molecules derived
from pyruvate-- that is,
lactate and alanine--
into mitochondrial oxaloacetate.
Then the mitochondrial pool
is converted from oxaloacetate
into malate, which
exits the mitochondrion.
And the molecules now
represent a malate pool
that's in the cytosol.
That malate pool, which began as
pyruvate, alanine, and lactate,
is converted to oxaloacetate.
And lastly, our
new enzyme, PEPCK,
converts the oxaloacetate
into cytoplasmic
phosphoenolpyruvate.
All that this was done
in order to bypass
the one-way step between
phosphoenolpyruvate
and pyruvate.
In other words, I can go
from phosphoenolpyruvate
to pyruvate quite easily
by pyruvate kinase.
But because this reaction
is so strongly exothermic,
I cannot go the other way.
The reverse step
is irreversible.
The mini-network that
we've just navigated
with all of its steps,
some of which require ATP,
was done in order to bypass the
irreversible pyruvate kinase
reaction.
We've just worked very hard
to move atoms from pyruvate,
alanine, and lactate
into the cytosol, where
those atoms are now packaged
as PEP, or phosphoenolpyruvate.
Now, let's focus on
phosphoenolpyruvate,
and let it flow backward through
the reverse of glycolysis all
the way up to the next
irreversible step at fructose
1,6-bisphosphate.
All of the steps between
phosphoenolpyruvate
and fructose 1,6-bisphosphate
are common to both
gluconeogenesis and glycolysis.
Fructose 1,6-bisphosphate
cannot be converted to fructose
6-phosphate by reversal of the
PFK 1, phosphofructokinase 1,
enzymatic step.
That step is too
thermodynamically irreversible.
Consequently, Nature invented
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase.
We saw the mechanism of that
enzyme earlier in the lecture.
It allows the conversion of
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate
to fructose 6-phosphate.
Then the molecule continues
upstream to form glucose
6-phosphate.
And once again, a
gluconeogenic-specific enzyme,
glucose 6-phosphatase, will
convert glucose 6-phosphate
into glucose.
Lastly, the manufactured glucose
is exported from the cell
by the glucose transporter.
So while it was a long
passage, the carbon atoms
from alanine and lactate
have traveled all the way
to glucose.
And then the glucose has
been sent out of the cell.
That is, their carbons are now
incorporated into the molecules
of glucose that go off from
the liver and renal cortex
to organs that need glucose
to meet their energy
needs, or their needs
for the glucose skeleton
for other biochemical purposes.
Gluconeogenic precursor
three is glutamate.
This is the amino acid
equivalent of the organic acid
alpha ketoglutarate.
So look at alpha ketoglutarate
at about 3 o'clock
on the TCA cycle.
You'll see glutamate
precursor three
being de-aminated by a
PLP-mediated process.
This converts glutamate
into alpha ketoglutarate.
Most of the carbons of
the alpha ketoglutarate
will then move clockwise
around the TCA cycle,
and end up at about
9 o'clock as malate.
Then, as we saw for
precursors one and two,
the malate will be exported
from the mitochondrion.
And next, most of its atoms will
find their way back to glucose,
just as we saw with alanine
and lactate earlier.
Precursor four is aspartic acid.
Aspartic acid is the amino acid
equivalent of oxaloacetate.
Aspartate is de-aminated
into oxaloacetate,
which enters the gluconeogenic
pathway at about 10 o'clock
on the TCA cycle.
At this point, the oxaloacetate
formed from aspartate
joins the oxaloacetate made from
alanine and lactate, precursors
one and two, and continues
all the way back to glucose.
Gluconeogenic precursor five
comes from odd-chained fatty
acids, which are depicted
way over on the right
of the metabolic map.
As we have seen,
odd-chain fatty acids
are catabolized into
three- carbon compounds,
such as propionyl coenzyme
A. One of the carboxlysases,
propionyl coenzyme
A carboxylase,
will add a carbon to this
three-carbon molecule.
Then methylmalonyl-coenzyme
A mutase and its partner,
epimerase, will
complete conversion
of the three-carbon
propionyl-CoA
to the four-carbon product
succinyl-CoA, which will then
integrate into the TCA cycle.
Succinyl-coenzyme A enters
at about five o'clock
on the TCA cycle.
The carbons then flow
clockwise to malate.
Just as we've seen before,
most of those carbons
will flow all the way back
to be built into glucose.
Gluconeogenic precursors
indicated by number six
are the amino acids, isoleucine,
methionine, and valine.
These are, once again, way
over on the right-hand side
of the figure.
These amino acids are also
converted to propionyl-CoA.
And just as with the
odd-chain fatty acids,
they will be converted
into succinyl-coenzyme A.
Then their atoms
follow the pathway
all the way back to glucose, as
we have seen now several times.
Slightly to the left
of center, you'll
see gluconeogenic
precursor number
seven, which is glycerol.
Glycerol is a tri-alcohol
produced from the metabolism
of complex lipids.
It derives from the
three-carbon backbone
that holds fatty acids and
phosphates by ester linkages.
Glycerol is first phosphorylated
to glycerol 3-phosphate.
And then that
product is oxidized
to dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
We've seen this
chemistry before.
From DHAP, or
dihydroxyacetone phosphate,
the molecules flow leftward
on the chart to fructose
1,6-bisphosphate, and then
they continue on through
gluconeogenesis to glucose.
Lastly, precursor
number eight is ribose.
We mainly obtain
ribose from our diet.
In the next lecture, I'm going
to cover the pentose phosphate
pathway.
In this pathway,
ribose from the diet
will enter what I call
the "carbon scrambling
phase" of the pentose
phosphate pathway.
Ribose goes into the
carbon scrambling
phase of the pathway,
and GAP, glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and fructose
6-phosphate come out.
Both of these molecules, GAP
and fructose 6-phosphate,
will flow from right to
left all the way to glucose
in the pathway that I've
drawn out in Panel C. Hence,
ribose is a good
gluconeogenic precursor.
Let me summarize the
functional dimensions
of the gluconeogenesis
pathway from a high altitude.
Imagine that overnight,
as you sleep,
you're not consuming any food.
Consequently, at some
point, your blood sugar
is going to drop.
Your gluconeogenic organs,
the liver and renal cortex,
will sense this
drop in blood sugar,
and turn on the hatched-line
pathways we've seen above,
in order to take readily
available noncarbohydrate
precursors, such as lactate,
alanine, ribose, and so on,
and convert those
noncarbohydrate precursors
into glucose.
The liver and renal cortex
will then send that glucose out
into the bloodstream
to client organs,
for example, the brain, red
blood cells, and renal medulla.
Ultimately, these
client organs will
be able to rely on a
constant level of glucose.
That, in a nutshell, is the role
of the gluconeogenic pathway.